This is our handpicked guide for you and your weekend.
Ross, do you wanna kick us off with a pick?
I do wanna kick you off.
I'll tell you this, I have been obsessed with cake week.
Anyone else, right?
So I'm, in that spirit,
I want you all to follow Chelsweets on Instagram.
Chelsey White's baking is so colorful,
so inventive, and so cute!
She makes these teeny tiny little cakes that come in
the perfect little size, 'cause it's like,
oh my God, I ate a whole cake.
Who cares if they're this big, right?
And we wanna thank Chelsea for these
tiny little treats we've got right here.
Everyone go to Chelsweets.com
to join Chelsea's baking club right now.
And how cute are these little cakes?
I feel like I'm having an aha moment
because this is the perfect marriage
between a cake and a cupcake.
Love these, thanks Chels.
To play, Box One!
That's right, it's a board game for one,
entirely designed by Neil Patrick Harris.
I'm playing it right now.
And it is super intelligent, super surprising,
super intriguing, and just straight up clever.
Really, really, really good.
How about this, to give.
'Tis the season.
Why not give the gift of cake?
And this week on the show
we've hopefully been inspiring you to love cake again.
And now you can send a cake for a cause
thanks to Sofia Vergara.
I love her and I love her more now.
She's teamed up with Kiva,
which is a platform that gives COVID loans
to small businesses that need the help right now.
And every cake you buy from one of their bakeries,
and there are a bunch of 'em, like Porto's in Los Angeles,
or Magnolia here in New York City.
They support entrepreneurs who need it.
They give loans to them with
the money they raise with these cakes.
Go to cakeforkiva.com.
You can get yourself some cakes
and give entrepreneurs some just desserts.
Oh, I love this.
And now, a quick little pick from my yellow book.
It's something to read.
I'm reading it right now.
It's "Funny Weather" by Olivia Laing.
And it's a collection of essays about the power of art,
especially during trying times.
Hmm, that's very apropos.
Olivia suggests art can actually make change.
And I agree.
I also think a lot about the roaring '20s
or art that came out of the '60s.
When we have these kind of seismic shifts in our world,
in our culture, there will be extraordinary things
that come out on the other side.
I love that, Drew.
And that's such a good silver lining to put on trying times,
that beautiful things do come out of it, right?
I think we could get into the roaring '20s, Ross.
Don't get, oh, you wanna flapper?
A little.
(both humming)
Okay, I don't know what that dance was, but.
If you wanna buy "Funny Weather",
or any books this gift giving season,
please shop one of my favorite bookstores.
It's the Future bookstore in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
I love this eclectic shop, and they're in our
little book of small businesses gift guide.
Closed for COVID, but shop online.
And you can get crystals and take a breathwork Zoom class.
I've been to this bookstore, it is great.
You've been there in person?
Yes, it's one of my favorite cities, Minneapolis.
And I have been there and loved it.
Well, if it wasn't 2020, I'd say let's go down to JFK,
and hop on a plane, and go to Minneapolis.
2021 goals, deal?
2021, we're going to Minneapolis.
And we're getting tater tots, that's a deal.
One last weekender, it's to wear.
It's a classic boot for the perfect occasion.
And it's, look, these Uggs, Drew!
Obsessed.
They're one of the best companies, in my opinion.
Ooh, I like this.
That, I know, the little ear muffs.
Yeah, my ears always get really cold too.
Freezing.
So now, not that these are mine,
but I now know where to find them.
And look, some of this stuff
I'd never seen from Ugg before.
Okay, well, to celebrate, they've launched
Feel Love campaign to honor real world heroes
in New York City community this season.
And in that holiday spirit, Ugg is gifting us today.
All the VFFs, I hope you like your feet cozy,
because you're all getting $150 Ugg gift card.
Hey, how about that!
Look at 'em.
Oh, they're so excited.
Thank you, Ross.
You're the best partner in crime a girl could ever hope for.
You're the best partner in crime, Drew.
Well that was The Weekender!
(dynamic music)